the ps4 was a fantastic console a
platform that both
indie and aaa games flocked to and
shined on bolstered by a varied lineup
of first party exclusives
sony's fourth console commanded the
attention of gamers for the past seven
years
while the ps4 success was undeniably a
good thing for sony
it leaves the company with the tough
challenge of topping itself
with the ps5 instead of simply releasing
a new console with more horsepower
sony has taken a bold step to clearly
establish that this
is a brand new generation the ps5's
console design speaks to this
looking less like a playstation and more
like an evil mega corp cyberpunk
headquarters
it's a brash design that looks nice when
standing tall
and a little strange when resting on its
side but in either
orientation it's undeniably eye-catching
the next generation machine is big bold
and next to stablemates like the ps4 pro
downright intimidating
though it may be a cold behemoth in its
stature the ps5 is also warm and
inviting when turned on
[Music]
the menus create a sense of familiarity
that helps users get their feet planted
but it's also stripped down
and streamlined installed games stand in
a line of up to nine titles on the home
page
capped off by a library button that
reveals your full collection
this is similar to the ps4 though
unfortunately there's currently no way
to organize these games at launch
whatever was used most recently shows up
first and there are no folders
sorting sizeable libraries by platform
is easy though
allowing you to parse which games are
native to the ps5
in just a few button presses navigating
the ps5 user interface
is just as easy being able to quickly
slide in and out of specific sections
back to your game and then into the
deeper system settings feels more fluid
and doing all of this with the new dual
sense controller is a delight
it's slightly bigger than the dualshock
4 and features new ergonomics
this extends to the shoulder buttons and
triggers which are now thicker
and feel smoother to press the
directional pad and face buttons also
feel less stiff
and while the analog sticks are the same
size as the dualshock 4s
they feature more grip and a slightly
more concave form factor making them
easier to hold onto
sony requires you to use the dualsense
for all ps5 games
relegating backwards compatible
controllers strictly to ps4 titles
this may wreak of a company pushing a
gimmick but after weeks of testing the
controller's unique features
the dualsense's haptic feedback and
adaptive triggers
have proven themselves to be much more
than that
astros playroom comes with every ps5 and
not only is it an enjoyable bite-sized
platformer but it's also a fantastic
showpiece for the dual sense controller
as astro's little robot feet walk on
metal floors
over a sandy beach or across an icy
surface you feel the difference in
impact
thanks to the enhanced haptic feedback
but where the dual sense truly impresses
is with its adaptive triggers when astro
comes across weapons like a bow or a
minigun
the triggers react in kind to
differentiate how it feels to use them
drawing the bose string instills tension
into the trigger while firing the
minigun
causes it to pop back as each bullet
fires
the dual sense delivers a tangible
sensation that enhances the enjoyment of
an already cute
and charming platformer then there's
spider-man where the dual senses unique
features are utilized in more subtle
ways
feeling the subway tracks beneath you as
spider-man hitches a ride or hitting the
small cushion of feedback when pulling
the triggers to web swing
isn't as pronounced as what you'll feel
in astros playroom
but it is enough to bring your hands and
what's happening on screen
a little closer together using the dual
sense is a pleasant experience and i
look forward to playing with it more
like many console specific features it
all depends on how developers utilize it
my hope is that we continue to see
developers put them to good use
because so far when the dual senses
potential is utilized
it creates tactile experiences that
enhance games
in surprisingly meaningful ways the ps4
pro
was able to deliver some excellent
gaming experiences but players were
often asked to choose between visuals
and performance
sacrificing one for the other while
these types of options are again
available in some ps5 games
the system is better equipped to provide
a more ideal experience
no matter your particular preference as
you'd expect the ps5 boasts much more
powerful specs than its predecessor
these afford the console enough power to
run a high-speed open-world game like
spider-man miles morales
at 4k and a solid 30 frames per second
with ray tracing enabled
or in a performance mode that enables
the game to run at 4k
and a solid 60 frames per second with
ray tracing disabled
both modes are immensely impressive even
to someone who spends most of his time
gaming on a high end pc with ray tracing
enabled
seeing the sun peek at you between new
york high rises or even catching the
reflection of the city in the glass
windows of a building
is enough to inspire you to stop
swinging and just look around
and at the same time running a game at
4k and 60 frames per second
and still getting a gorgeous image is
incredibly exciting
both graphics modes make miles morales
feel like a next-gen game
because while you're definitely trading
visuals for performance neither mode
feels like a compromise
third-party games offering even more
options that work
just as well such as 120 hertz support
help prove that the ps5 is a huge step
up over the ps4 pro yes the ps5's power
is impressive but the console's tech
headliner is a custom solid state drive
that weighs in at 825 gigabytes and read
speeds of 5.5
gigabytes per second this is quick
storage
outmatching most ssds you can currently
buy on the market
and spider-man miles morales serves as a
great test case for this speed
loading into the new web slinging
adventure from the home page
takes less than 10 seconds and once
you're swinging around manhattan
you'll only wait a couple more to fast
travel anywhere around the huge open
world
this stark improvement ensures you're
spending more time playing and less time
waiting for the game to load
but it also benefits the actual
streaming of the open worlds
i encountered no stuttering at all
during my time with it
now sony requires all ps5 games to run
off this internal ssd
this ensures that these next-gen
experiences have the bandwidth they need
but with this requirement and the
ever-growing sizes of games
that puts the ssd's storage space at a
premium
after system data and updates you have
about 667 gigabytes for your games
this wouldn't be as big of a problem if
you could store games on an external
drive and transfer them to the console
when you want to play them
unfortunately the ps5 is not capable of
this
at launch for now you can only use
external drives for playing backwards
compatible ps4 games
the ssd also plays a huge part in some
of the ps5's unique smart features
pressing the home button on the dual
sense controller pops up the control
center
this menu displays a number of
activities that show available
challenges trophies and even your
progress at a specific level
in supported games what makes this a
particularly compelling feature
is that the available activities adapt
to your game as you play
offering up-to-date help and suggestions
selecting a specific level or
challenge pushes the game to load it
immediately and the ssd
handles this quickly using this i
completed all of spider-man's stealth
challenges without needing to travel
through the open world to each mission
marker
the most helpful aspect of these
activities is the inclusion of video
guides
near the end of my time with astros
playroom i was struggling to find the
few remaining collectibles
astro tells you exactly which sections
you're missing a collectible in and
selecting that specific
section's card brings up the option for
a video guide
the ps5 knew exactly which collectible i
was missing and showed me a short 10
second video of where i could find it
of course this will only work with
supported games but hopefully developers
will flock to this new
feature because when it's used well it
improves the overall experience
sony has loaded the ps5 with a slate of
accessibility options at launch
these include the ability to lessen the
dual sensor's effects enable a
text-to-speech screen reader
transcribe voice chat and turn on video
captions
these features are accurate to their
descriptions and work
quite well these features show a
significant improvement over what the
ps4 offered at launch and will no doubt
be appreciated by users
who are now being given more opportunity
to experience games and use the ps5 in a
way that's comfortable for them
with more people being able to use the
ps5 from the get-go
you hope that sony will continue to
iterate on these options
and evolve its support as the console
grows
additionally the ps5 allows for setting
your difficulty
graphics mode language subtitles
preference and
inverted camera controls at the system
level the latter of which can bypass
specific game settings if they don't
offer inverted controls
for users that need this for the most
comfortable gaming experience
it's a nice feature to have some of
these other settings however
will depend on if the game supports
those options
some games don't have difficulty
settings or graphics modes
and some don't have subtitles or any
other language but
english this is a great feature for the
ps5
so hopefully developers take note and
work to support it
throughout this year sony has touted its
tempest 3d audio tech which will only be
available for headphones at launch
after a few weeks of testing i'm left a
little underwhelmed
what i've noticed so far from the ps5 3d
audio tech is that it provides a slight
boost
to directional audio this was the most
pronounced in the ssd speedway level of
astros playroom where cars fly by you as
you glide through the opening
area the engines of the speeding
vehicles sound louder and more distinct
almost as if they are narrowly missing
your head 3d audio generally works quite
well with first person games like
shooters and quieter horror games like
the resonate evil series
however games need to support the ps5 3d
audio tech to take full advantage of it
so we weren't able to test examples of
either genre ahead of launch
as it is the 3d audio is a bonus that
doesn't necessarily feel essential or
substantially different
for any experience i've had so far
however
it doesn't make the audio worse and is
also compatible with any headset that
works with the ps5
so there's really no reason not to use
it
sony has said that the ps5's backwards
compatibility doesn't support
100 of the ps4s library but it's
slightly more complicated than that
the ps5 is capable of playing the vast
majority of the ps4s best games but they
may not behave
quite like they did on the original
console starting up resident evil 7
we immediately noticed a visual glitch
dominating the sky above the baker's
house
instead of the hazy clouds blocking out
the louisiana sun
the sky looked like an oil painting
aside from some minor glitches however
playing backwards compatible games on
the ps5 is
very similar to playing them on the ps4
i was able to download my ps4 saves from
the cloud and continue my arcane build
in bloodborne
carry on with my assault on the invading
mongols and ghost of tsushima
and finally get back to playing my god
of war save all of the ps4 games we
tested
showcased frame rates in line with or in
some cases
improved over the original console to
see how the ps5's power is utilized by
backwards compatible games
we sought out titles that released with
uncapped frame rates
two prominent examples were capped in an
update due to performance issues
which meant we had to find physical
copies which let us disconnect from the
internet and play unpatched
batman return to arkham put up a poor
performance in arkham city's open world
on the ps4
starting it up on the ps5 the system
flashed a warning message
specifically stating this game may not
behave correctly on the new console
batman return to arkham was the only
game that we came across to display this
message
but we didn't notice much in terms of
bizarre behavior
however its performance as a whole is
disappointing with noticeable drops in
the frame rate as you fly around the
open worlds
it's hard to pinpoint if this is a
compatibility problem or an issue with
the game itself
as further tests prove the ps5 is
capable of improving
and stabilizing uncapped frame rates
assassin's creed unity was a great
example of this
the ps5 offers a much smoother
experience here with similar
improvements to those digital foundry
found when testing the game on the xbox
series x
the ps5 keeps the frame rate going
strong no matter what you do
this is a monumental improvement over
what we saw at the game's launch in 2014
and while you will come across bugs here
and there it's still
very playable without any patches
surprisingly
load times don't see as big an
improvement as we expected
when compared to the ps4 the ps5's
internal
ssd has marked if not drastic
improvements in multiple games like
bloodborne and final fantasy 7 remake
when compared to the xbox series x's
internal storage however
a different picture gets painted on the
ps5 final fantasy xv
takes 1 minute and 10 seconds from
launch to gameplay
this beats out the ps4 which comes in at
almost 3 minutes
but doesn't match up to the series x
which only takes 43 seconds to perform
the same task likewise
monster hunter world took 51 seconds on
the ps5
and only 29 on the series x
ps5 compatibility patches are where the
big gains are seen
days gone and ghosts of tsushima have
been upgraded to take advantage of the
new hardware
and both games have noticeable
performance boosts
day's gone is now much smoother
targeting 60 frames per second with a
dynamic 4k resolution
ghost of tsushima sees a similar boost
in frame rate with the resolution mode
making the performance mode feel
unnecessary on the ps5
these patches bring these ps4 games in
line with the performance and fidelity
of ps5 titles
giving new life to games that deserved
stronger hardware in the first place
at launch the ps5 is an excellent
console that paves the way for a
promising future where gaming
experiences can evolve in interesting
ways
and the process of experiencing them is
streamlined
its custom ssd unique dual sense
controller and powerful specs
draw a distinct line between last
generation and the next
faster loading times and system features
like the ps5's activities
make the ssd feel essential while the
dual sense's substantial feedback
makes a strong case for moving on from
the dualshock 4.
of course the performance and visuals
that the ps5 is capable of pushing
offer excellent experiences no matter
what graphics mode you prefer
and even though it's backwards
compatibility implementation
isn't perfect it's still exciting to
know that i can play most of my ps4
library on this new console with few
if any issues i even tested guitar hero
live which thank god
works very well of course the ps5 can't
survive on its backwards compatible
games alone and all consoles ultimately
come down to the quality of their
dedicated libraries
beyond that many of the console's best
features such as the adaptive triggers
and activities
require developers to opt in and support
them
sony has laid strong foundations for its
new generation of gaming
but it's now up to developers to use all
the tools laid out for them
to build upon it with what we've seen so
far from the console's hardware
and games like spider-man and astro this
next generation has the potential to be
great for playstation
and i'm excited to see it
[Music]
you